this thing that we thought was good like
hey what if everyone just felt really
good about themselves like that's good
if you earn it if you just rub it on
them that ain't earning it and that's
gonna lead to trouble you link a lot of
this stuff that's happening on colleges
in the movie you link it to sort of how
we've raised kids now so you want to
want to kick the millennials while
they're down I do I do as I as I travel
through this land I think I think the
self-esteem movement has really is
really the genesis of this we started
because I started thinking like when I
was 19 I I didn't have any self esteem
and my thing was like I'm not gonna tell
an adult what to do like I would never
dream if I was walking down the street
and I was like 16 and I passed a 45 year
old guy and he's like hey stop not well
I need to go give me 20 push-ups
okay diamond hands are kind of do a wide
spread like I would have just done it
because he's a dude he's older than me
and he told me to do something that's
how I was wired so I started thinking
like well if I were 19 and I was on a
college campus and I was on a
construction site but if I was on a
college campus by the way when I was on
a construction site I had a 4-1 go he
said go to my truck get my 4 foot level
out of my gun rack yeah like a four foot
level hang a nice gun rack and I said
okay and I started walking a truck and
he goes hey run and I started running
cuz he told me to run he's older than I
am and it was like a gun rack so it was
probably wise yeah where's the gun here
run it probably was at all levels in
their running serpentine so I started
thinking if I was 19 and I was on a
college campus and they announced that
some 50 year old with a bunch of degrees
was coming to speed
I wouldn't ever go like not a over my
dead body
I just feel like okay all right and then
someone would go well Adam he's gonna
talk about stuff you disagree with and
I'd go well he's 50 and has all the
degrees so I guess I'm probably wrong
and then someone would go dude does he
have the right to speak here and I go
course it's not my campus I'm just I'm
basically this is a four-year motel I'm
living at I don't own the building like
who know about something for me to and
then if they went
we're gonna go rally and make them
create a human blockade I'd be like why
what just don't go to the show well I
don't I don't get it and I realize sort
of like a sane functioning person that's
what you're saying you would have acted
like a that should be well how high does
your self-esteem have to be to go not on
my watch no way is is David Rubin or
Jordan sorry Jordan Rubin or they've
been chuck parasites we're combining all
these people by I'm in the woods what
horrible transforming yeah that's gonna
be protested why would why why would
that be my job Who am I to do that so if
you think about what that takes that
takes a life of grooming that takes a
life of don't let anyone tell you what
to do you tell them what did it like
you're special your opinion matters
don't let anybody you know out serve the
self-esteem movement I believe is super
dangerous I mean how you gonna put world
war ii get in a higgins landing craft
and go hit normandy nineteen-year-olds
with super high self-esteem you think
they're getting in that thing you think
they're gonna rush out of german pillbox
hell no no so this thing that we thought
was good like hey what if everyone just
felt really good about themselves like
that's good if you earn it if you do
rub it on them that ain't earning it and
that's gonna lead to trouble so if we go
a little meta on that do you think
that's actually by design do you think
that is just like it's sort of just kind
of like Liberals that wanted everybody
to feel good and it's just kind of nice
or do you think it was actually by
designed by some some bad actors that
push this stuff out there to to weaken
all of the things that that the movies
about I think it can be traced back to a
gentleman who's out of Los Angeles who
had an idea which is like it was an all
paraphrase but it's like some of these
inner city kids and some of these
low-income kids or single-parent kids
and stuff they have low self-esteem but
they don't their dad abandoned them look
they don't feel good about themselves
and if they felt good about themselves
they would start excelling in school and
get out of gangs and not be involved
with crime so how do we get them to feel
good about themselves and it's like well
we can't get their dad back in the house
and we can't give them an A in calculus
when they're failing calculus we're just
going to start telling them how good
they are and they'll feel good about
themselves and whatever happening is it
turns out like criminals have high
self-esteem they know it's a unintended
circumstance like I have a good heart
you know it's basically all that stuff
of like I have a good heart
let's build big housing projects and let
people live in free in those and we'll
give them food and we'll level it's like
yeah you're over I'm good
it all sounds good you have a great
heart you've now ruined a group of
people that's how you ruin people you
you tell them you give them things
without earning it you give them food
without earning it you give them housing
without earning it or you give them
self-esteem without earning it you don't
earn it it doesn't work it morphs into
something bad and then comes back in a
weird kind of vitriolic way so one of
the things I kept thinking during the
movie is over the last couple years has
I've had all these people on I mean so
many of the people in the movie
have been in here to discuss the very
things there they're bringing up in the
movie I've often thought man am i over
blowing this like am I am I just
exaggerating or am I just finding these
random people Lindsey Shepherd this.ta
at Wilfrid Laurier University in Canada
which I had never heard of before am i
over blowing this and and then the
answer always turned out to be no
because the next week there's somebody
else that it happens to in the next week
there's somebody else and the rest of it
but were you ever worried about that
that as you make this that it like makes
it feel like it's bigger than it is or
the or do you really believe that it is
this big I think when you when you
endeavor to do any kind of storytelling
there's a balance between making it
compelling and I know this I'll give you
an example and then I'll circle back
I've made other documentaries about
subjects that have nothing to do with
this and I made a documentary about Paul
Newman and it's racing life and it's
called winning the racing life of Paul
Newman and you're your audience would
enjoy it his partner his teammate and
his like best friend and teammate died
in a race in Florida
Paul was racing he was racing
Fitzie was his name he died in the race
he died they think because he had a
heart attack when he was driving the car
and just never slowed down for like turn
three and just plowed in the wall and
died and when you're making the film I'm
saying it's more dramatic if he just
never hit the brakes on turn three and
gotten this horrific accident and died
now the truth is he had a heart attack
probably and died and then hit the wall
and died for sure or broke his neck or
whatever it is and as a filmmaker I'm
like I don't want to lie but I'd like to
make this dramatic
so I took out the part where he probably
was dead from the heart attack and just
said he went down the straightaway he
never break four turn three he died when
he hit the wall you know and so there's
this kind of thing where it's like don't
lie but you're also making a film like
you're trying to entertain I think
what's going on on college campuses is
bad I have 13 year old twins I have
reservations about sending them to
college and I do hear the stories and I
don't like the stories but on this by
the same token you're trying to make a
film that holds people's interest and
the music swells of you and you take a
little artistic license and it's a
dramatic shot of the smoke burning in
slow motion and stuff and yeah so of
course there's an element of like we are
gonna massage it you know like they do
in in the you know in theatrical
filmmaking as well there's it's speaking
to the same party a brain like you want
people to sit up pay attention and and
what-have-you and it's just a part of
filmmaking so the answer is sort of yes
and yes I do think it's bad but also you
take some artistic license and ratchet
it up if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
comedy instead of the non-stop yelling
you get everywhere else check out our
comedy playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell